in deep chain a design requires a
three-dimensional protein complex
structure
either experimentally resolved or
modeled computationally
deep chain currently supports protein
data bank format for these
and you can either upload one using a
local file or simply type in the four
character code
of a pdb structure from a design you
will be able to explore protein
sequences
in the playground run molecular dynamics
simulations
or use the ai designer to conduct
mutagenesis experiments
let's create one now in the new design
tab
enter your design name for me it will be
defensin
and select your data source in this case
it will be a local file
describing a defense in six complex
using a local file is the default option
and there it is i can visualize my
structure on the left
and start working on it now for a given
project
you might be interested in not one but
several complexes that your protein of
interest forms
perhaps an example from a different
species or a structure of a mutant
for my defensing project i found one in
a pdb file
that i would like to analyze more
closely
it is a structure of a variant where h
histidine 27
was mutated to w tryptophan which made
it unable to block
invasions i can create another design in
deep chain from this complex just by
using the 4 character pdb id
all i need to do here is to create a new
design let's call it simply defense
invariant here
select four character pdb id as a data
source
enter my code 3 q t
e and hit create design
finally i realized that my first design
was not appropriately named
i can rename it by going to the upper
section of the screen
where my active design is displayed and
rename it there
there it is we've seen how to create
designs both from a local file
or from the rcsb pdb and how to rename
them
thanks so much for your attention and
enjoy deep chain